[Musique]
il ya un truc karim en france une
nouvelle émission je voulais absolument
vous la montrer ça s'appelle naked
attractions oui est-ce que vous avez vu
le concept est simple des candidats à la
recherche de l'amour se met à nu et de
leurs tenues seront choisis que sur un
seul critère leur corps c'est à dire que
nous ici on peut rester huit ans déjà il
m'a dit non sans arrêt nous et ça veut
dire frères c'est pas on n'est pas
choisie prêt à s' est et est égale à une
catastrophe
leurs visages ne sera élevé et révélé
qu'à la fin disponible en version foot
et sur 6 mais aujourd'hui tout est
visible à 22h30 sur le site de la chaîne
et ça va arriver je crois que m6 va le
faire c'est fort
est ce que vous aimez cette émission est
ce que vous avez envie de la voir ce que
donne envie d'y participer
howl howl le gie goon est le digg ou n'y
allèrent le zig uni a l'air déjà
retrouvé deux ans si c'est nice
maintenant je commence à le regretter
découvrons ce que les femmes et les
hommes trouvent réellement attirant
c'est fantastique
est-ce que choisir un partenaire
uniquement sur le physique peut mieux
faire
permettra de trouver le bon
je suis est simplement parfait nous le
saurons dans cette émission tu choisir
you take que les décisions ne procurent
de ma vie et oui alors qui a envie de
voir cette émission avec jimmy avait
retenu les égouts ni non moi je déteste
les émissions on se sert d'un prétexte
bidon juste pour voir des gens à poil en
fait au début oui dans notre société
matérialiste les vêtements comporte nous
empêche de montrer qui on est vraiment
en fait tu voulais juste montrer des
gens
ça me rappelle les enjeux ont fait
croire qu'ils sont à miami pour trouver
du travail
est-ce que vous avez ce que vous seriez
capable ou de choisir un homme juste sur
son site vous êtes débit c'est pour moi
une table juste juste sur son agonie
gérad banon
non un sexe qu'un sexe non mots vrais
morts qui d'un tout c'est vrai je pense
qu'il faut arrêter d'être vous avez
entendu comme un peu avant de voir le
gig uni de votre nom quelques quelques
jours dans quelques mois quelques mois
avant d'aller aux égouts noah la part du
programme
c'est lorsque les candidats découvrent
leurs prétendants et découvre surtout
leur guigou 17 rien n'arrivera jamais en
france 6,6 à ces pays de long 6 il y
déjà oui mais sur sester j'y crois moyen
chez sébastien être fait pareil mais j'y
crois moyen ça va arriver personne
qu'ils ont mais non sur ce plateau vous
êtes une bande d'hypocrites
on va regarder les égouts ni la bière
jamais oui mais voilà la salive un bon
carnet d'accord vous avez vu vous vous
avez vu au bout de combien de temps le
gic ont mis notre bon sens
parce qu'on s'était séparé de deux
semaines oui je trouve que c'est
réaliste
de quoi d'avoir des égaux ni non mais
c'est irréaliste comme émissions et et
et je trouve que ça ça nous change les
idées oui moi je trouve pas besoin de
rire en ce moment avec le confinement et
qu'est ce qui marche dans la vie eh ben
c'est la bouffe et le cul je suis désolé
trés bien l'écouter c'est bien de le
dire d'emblée vu moi ce que j'aime c'est
la franchise de nathalie marquay voilà
oui mais vous rendez compte des valeurs
que ça renvoie ya plein de jeunes qui
regardent ça la première chose qu'on
monte chez quelqu'un qu'on va rencontrer
de l'hypocrisie
mesdames et hypocrite au ritz à la clé
mais leur corps et c est ce qu on fait
ça est ce que tu as un gros sexe etc
ça crée des complexes et légère à kaunas
mais c'est quoi ces malheureux même
s'ils s'en fout excellent sixième alors
bas des jeunes on a laissé pas défoncer
le programme sam et 30 secondes des
français j'ai pas besoin de le défense
et je suis quand même d'accord avec
guillaume anor des 90 56 guillaume ai
pas parlé voilà vous voulez bien oui
effectivement c'est plus honnête de dire
venez regarder des cures guère évolué
ensemble désir oui le devant et le
derrière la face et la fesse regardons
ça ensemble il n'y a pas besoin de
trouver un prétexte
intellect le concours pour justifier ça
et maintenant je sens que c'est un
programme qui se rassemblent plutôt
triste que fort is an maintenant je
regarderai parce que c'est mon boulot de
regarder alors là que gilbert d'elle je
sais pas du tout d'accord avec guillaume
sur les égoïsmes et oui bien sûr moi
j'ai regardé l'émission c'est vraiment
l'âme qui se reflète au travail
bien sûr il faut tout regarder il faut
tout regarder et moi je regrette qu'on
ne voit pas le visage mais après les
gens se dévoie c'est le ton t on choisir
on choisit un zegoulli parce qu'il
appartient à une âme
mais l'écolo pernikoff écoutez moi j'ai
trouvé ça très drôle léger et puis ça va
au delà juste du physique puisqu'il ya
pas mal d change assez marrant qui sont
faits avec les candidats on voyait déjà
la femme est voilée assise là par contre
ça très drôle et très marquée ce convoi
avant le visage et le sexe bien
évidemment de quoi vite le sexy ni non
[Musique]
moi ce qui me plaît pas en fait dans ce
que tu dis gilles malgré tout je sais
que si c'est les igg uni ça va pour toi
si on y avait vu la villette xe
il ya aussi juste il a raison parce qu'à
rajouter quand même étonné si opel un
truc à manger un truc a énormément
démission de dating qui ont été
développées genre une centaine ont quand
même dans le monde et elles se sont tous
plantés la tête basse et sainte être un
peu audacieux de la part de m6 mais
peut-être que ça va être enfin le dating
qui va marcher car là ça commence aussi
goody lyonnais grâce à ses coups